falls ihr auch einige Orangenschalen
übrig habt zeige ich euch heute ein paar
Möglichkeiten wie ihr sie verwerten
könnt Orangenschalen enthalten viel
Zitronensäure deswegen sind sie ein
toller kaltlöser also könnte es jetzt
z.B specken oder Wasser kochen verwenden
oftmals nehmen Kunststoffbehälter ja
gerne mal Gerüche an und dann könnt ihr
auch die Orangenscheiben nehmen die
Plastik und kunststoffschüsseln damit
ausreiben und danach auswaschen dann
werdet ihr eklige Gerüche los dann könnt
ihr immer auch ganz gerne Orangenschalen
im Ofen oder mit der Automaten trocknen
und das ganze als potpouri verwenden so
als schönen Duft zu Hause entweder
einfach auf dem Tisch irgendwo oder z.B
auch im Kleiderschrank denn Orangen
halten auch Motten fern und ihr könnt
dann z.B auch die getrockneten
Orangenschalen einfach vermixen mit
Zucker verrühren und dann ein Peeling
draus machen und wir könnten ganz tolles
Haarwasser machen was eure Haare schön
glänzen lässt und zwar für die
Orangenschale in ein Glas befüllt ist
Glas mit Apfelessig und lassen zwei Tage
stehen und dann wird alles mit Wasser
aufgefüllt und ihr könnt dann fürs Haar
benutzen